un momento esperado para los
trabajadores de la salud argentina
inició la vacunación contra el hobbit 19
en los 24 distritos del país con las
300.000 dosis de la vacuna rusa sputnik
el principio del fin a pesar de que las
seguimos peleando pero cuando tenemos fe
de que ahora
así que buena esperanza nada más es una
alegría inmensa porque hace mucho que
venimos esperando esto y venimos
luchando día a día con esta pandemia y
hemos visto muchos compañeros perder su
vida tanto enfermeros como médico y la
verdad que este es el esperanza en esta
primera etapa las inmunizaciones están
destinadas al personal de salud de
centros urbanos de unidades de terapia
intensiva y de laboratorios todos ellos
deberán aplicarse la segunda dosis del
fármaco en 21 días argentina prevé
contar con 51 millones de dosis de
vacunas 20 millones del sputnik 22,4 de
la de astrazéneca y 9 del mecanismo
cobach de la onu además sigue negociando
con los laboratorios pzifer sinovac y
scinopharm entre los primeros vacunados
estuvo el gobernador de la provincia de
buenos aires
axel kiciloff en un intento por
transmitir confianza en la vacuna
sputnik cuestionada desde algunos
sectores por no haber publicado su
información técnica uno de los médicos
vacunados defendió su seguridad la
vacuna tiene un diseño genético muy
interesante todos los datos reportados
demuestran su
está en el estándar del resto de las
vacunas de los otros laboratorios
argentina es el tercer país en comenzar
a aplicarla sputnik después de rusia y
belarús y la cuarta nación
latinoamericana en iniciar la vacunación
luego de méxico chile y costa rica que
utilizan el fármaco the fighter y bayón
tech